[Musique]
vim
c'est une petite caserne militaire comme
il en existe beaucoup en roumanie mais
celle de targoviste à 80 km de bucarest
n'a rien d'ordinaire
il suffit d'y entrer pour sentir toute
la morosité c'est tout comme si le 25
décembre 1989 le temps ci était arrêté
lionel est un militaire à la retraite il
était à l'époque parachutistes de
l'armée en mission secrète
il se souvient de tout comme si c'était
hier
mais là ça promet même de l'odeur de
l'autre colonne que portaient les
dictateurs
nicolas champ chez sprint car j'ai un
poste à exécuter visite médicale et
c'est dans cette petite pièce sombre que
le couple a été jugé condamné à mort en
moins d'une heure par un tribunal
improvisé nicolae ceausescu
la chine cherche quant à primer la
berline internationale à ceausescu a
même chanté l'internationale juste ici
en marchant vers le muret de la cour
arrière où le couple allait être exécuté
lionel était un des trois tireurs
il revient rarement sur les lieux même
s'il détestait les charges et secoue son
exécution sommaire ces images sont
encore aujourd'hui
j'ai un petit rab quand une touriste
française entend son récit elle n'en
croit pas ses oreilles vous rendez
compte que vous avez été l'instigateur
de la nouvelle histoire de la roumanie
[Musique]
positive au commissariat
trente ans plus tard les 6 4 et sont
bien enlever la révolution de 89,6 c'est
un espèce de malaise collectif comme en
témoignent ses monuments timide érigé à
la mémoire des victimes et de leurs
familles
[Musique]
catalina perdu son père qui est mort
sous les balles de la police secrète en
plein centre de bucarest
à 16 ans il s'était rendu avec lui place
de l'université pour chanter à tue-tête
qu'il réprime est depuis l'enfance ou de
dangereux comme sa femme nicole et en
avait 12
elle avait passé une nuit en prison
torturés par la securitate pour le
simple fait d'avoir manifesté contre le
président la mort des chaouche est ce qu
était une délivrance aux fausses
demandes extérieures des nord
l'extérieur des noms ils se sont
rencontrés des années plus tard tous les
deux orphelins d'une révolution qui nous
a été volée dit la pancarte qui traînent
dans le salon
[Applaudissements]
comme la majorité des roumains ils
considèrent que 89 était un coup d'état
bien orchestrée par l'ailé du parti
communiste qui demeure aujourd'hui un
pilier de la vie politique
aussi le dos people roumanie est membre
de l'union européenne depuis 12 ans la
roumanie demeure l'enfant terrible du
club s'il est un pays sous surveillance
n'a pas encore le rhône il passe par
europe est un pays corrompu où plus de
mille politiciens ont été inculpés pour
détournement de fonds y compris le grand
patron du psd le parti qui était au
pouvoir depuis trois ans
comment avancer dans les circonstances
dit nicoletta elle suit une thérapie qui
la mène chaque année dans la cellule où
elle a été battue enfants difficiles de
guérir dit elle quand on sait que celui
qui dirigeait l'établissement était
jusqu'à l'an dernier directeur du plus
grand pénitencier pour femmes du pays
[Musique]
millions d'euros site hospitalier
pas étonnant qu'autant de roumains
décident de plier bagage
les statistiques sur l'exode sont
troublantes la roumanie est le deuxième
pays d'origine des migrants dans le
monde tout juste après la sienne mais
surtout tout livre il a fallu en arriver
là pour que le citoyen retourne à la rue
bucarest est aujourd'hui le théâtre des
plus importants rassemblements
populaires depuis la chute du communisme
il ya trente essais 10 place de la
victoire le lieu de prédilection de la
nouvelle résistance qui côtoient
désormais les vieux révolutionnaire
politique et pour moi c'est tout à fait
logique d'être ici d'essayer de changer
la la faune politique de royer manifesté
beaucoup quand il faut oui
yu-na est revenu au bercail après deux
ans d'études en france pour se battre
entre autres contre une loi qui aurait
accordé l'amnistié imaginer aux
politiciens corrompus
on est la génération
et
elle est tirée du communisme et
qui au bout voile voilà nous sommes la
nouvelle génération qui peut un peu
questionné changé
le système politique marina une dentiste
de 29 ans a elle aussi reçu une offre
d'emploi l'étranger dont une au canada
mais la jeune maman résiste année après
année ait un jour inhabituel et oies et
ce but il faut qu'un prix
and we do not know a tu respectes of
meaning lionel ne sait toujours pas
comment il expliquera sa plus jeune de
13 ans si le geste qu'il a posé ici en
1989 en valait la peine de mort pour ce
que la roumanie est une démocratie
encore bien fragile
et katalin refuse de l'abandonner à
wikileaks à continuer à diffuser livre
mieux non à dormans tout débute tout bon
compromis entre vous on se battra
jusqu'à ce que le pays se relève dit
nicoletta - fo compte dans la rue avec
nos enfants comme mon père l'a fait avec
nous il y a trente ans